off the back of johnny depp giving his
take on their tumultuous marriage this
week we'll see amber heard take her turn
but before that the court heard from a
security guard of depths who'd witnessed
one particularly volatile late night row
which he tried to break up in march
2015.
i stepped
in between misheard and mr depp
at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
i heard and saw a
closed fist
contact
mr depp and the left side of his face
that was misheard's fifth the initial
look on his face um
kind of mirrored mine uh kind of a look
of shock like
what just happened where'd that come
from in a recorded deposition a nurse
hired to help herd with emotional and
anxiety issues was asked to talk through
her case notes including a visit she
made to deliver medication to the
actress in december 2015.
client had visible bright red blood
appearing at center of lower lip clients
stated it was from
injury sustained in the
and then it's blank you see that from
depth's talent manager came an
explanation of the financial fallout the
actor experienced after herd's
washington post piece was published with
respect to johnny it was it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist with depp's
witnesses now drawing to a close having
listened as her character was pulled
apart by his experts in the coming days
heard will now get to have her say katy
spencer sky news